All right. So, today we're we're
starting a new phase of the course,
which is going to be about games with
incomplete information.
And I'll warn you up front that the
terminology here is a bit confusing.
We've been talking about imperfect and
perfect information, and now we're
talking about complete and incomplete
information. Complete and perfect sound
kind of similar colloquially, but in
game theory they have very different
meanings. So, I want to be precise about
uh what's going on. So,
uh so far,
we've always looked at complete
information.
And what's confusing is that under
complete information, under this
complete information umbrella, there are
two special cases that we've talked
about, or two distinct cases, which is
perfect information
and imperfect information.
So, I'll give some formal definitions,
but then I'll also give some examples to
keep in mind cuz I think these
definitions can seem a bit abstract. So,
in games of perfect information, what
that meant was that every information
set was a singleton, right?
And I think the canonical game to keep
in mind for games of perfect information
would be games like chess.
So, when we play chess, whenever it's
our turn to move, we've can perfectly
see how everyone else has moved so far
in chess, right? We see the position of
the board and we remember each move that
everyone else played.
Uh that's the sense in which every
information set is a singleton.
Then we also looked at games of
imperfect information. What that meant
was that some information sets were not
singletons.
So, I'll say some
non-singleton
info sets.
Now, economically, what does it mean
when we had non-singleton information
sets? It meant that there were times
when someone was called upon to move
and there was some aspect of the game
that or of the previous moves they
didn't know about, either move by nature
or move by a different player. And they
knew which information set they were at,
but they didn't necessarily know uh or
they didn't know which node within that
information set they were at.
And uh
this was the case in a few There's a few
leading examples here.
Whenever we had a simultaneous move
game,
whenever the players move
simultaneously, remember the way we
represented that in the extensive form
was to say, "Well, technically one
player has moved first, but then the
other player moves without observing the
move by the other player." And
therefore, that second player's
information set is going to include
different nodes that specify how the
other player moved.
Uh
so, simultaneous moves in sort of the
simple example here, I would say, is
poker.
Think of uh
poker would be another case because when
I'm called upon to move in poker, I
don't know the cards that the other
players have been dealt. So, my
information set, even if we move
sequentially in poker, my information
set is still non-singleton because when
I move, I don't know uh what cards the
other player has. So, these are kind of
two distinct ways we can have um
imperfect information.
But,
why do I say both of these are complete
information?
So,
the defining feature, the defining
property of these two classes of games
is what makes them complete information.
And I'll warn you, some people give
slightly different definitions of this,
and I think my definition is slightly
different than what's given in the
notes. Um but what I like to think of it
is at the beginning of the game,
information is symmetric.
SO, BEGINNING OF THE GAME IS CRUCIAL
HERE, RIGHT? Once we start playing
poker,
we're going to be dealt hands, and one
player won't know what cards the other
player has been dealt.
But when we start the game, when we sit
down at the poker table, whatever one
player knows, everyone else knows. No
one's been dealt any cards yet. We all
understand the rules of the game. We all
understand that people want to win as
much money as possible, and information
is symmetric in the sense that um
anything
known by one player
is known by all players.
Uh and maybe if I want to be more
precise, I'll say it's common knowledge.
This doesn't mean we know everything,
right? When we sit down at the poker
table, we don't know what hands we're
going to be dealt in the future.
But none of us know that. There's no
information that one player knows that
other player just don't know at the
beginning of the game.
And it's crucial here that we're at the
The distinction with incomplete
information
And maybe I'll add, when I say
information is symmetric, let me add
here relevant information.
You know, of course, when you sit down
at the poker table, you know your
birthday and someone else doesn't,
right? But that's not really relevant to
the game. So, in a technical sense, we
never have complete information because
there's always these unmodeled things
that are relevant, but what I what I
mean is relevant information.
With incomplete information, the
difference is that at the beginning of
the game,
there is relevant information that some
player knows, but another player doesn't
know.
So, there is
information, or more precisely, relevant
information
that is known by some player, but not
others.
And let's give uh a few examples of
this.
So, examples of incomplete information
games. And what you'll see is that
a lot of our examples of complete
information games come from parlor
games. They come from things like chess
or poker. But in the real world, when
we're analyzing economic situations,
we're much more often in the incomplete
information So, let's uh let's give a
few examples of that.
I was a question? Yeah.
Uh no, never mind. Oh, you're welcome to
ask, but Oh, I thought you were asking
for Oh, oh, sure. Give an example. Yeah.
Sorry, sometimes I'm rhetorical, it's
not clear. Yeah, so always You can
always answer any question you want, and
if I didn't intend it, that's totally
fine. Yeah, go ahead. Um
would one of them be like when there's
price haggling and they don't know each
other's values? Exactly, that's a great
example. So, um
and actually that fits in The first
example I was going to give is kind of a
special case of that. So, let me let me
give kind of this is the kind of classic
example, and it exactly fits into your
setting, and this I would say is buying
a used car.
And of course, price haggling over the
used car.
Let's say we're haggling over the price
of the used car. What don't we know?
Well, you brought up one example, we
don't know each player's valuation for
the car. And we could be a little more
specific, right? Let's say a salesperson
is selling you a used car. There's
something they know that you don't,
probably, right? What what might they
know that you don't know about the car?
Uh
Yes, ma'am, in the second row. Yeah.
The actual condition The condition of
the car, right? So, in this case, the
seller, maybe they're an experienced
mechanic or auto dealer, they've seen a
lot of cars, they've examined the car
car closely. You maybe don't know a lot
about cars. So, often the seller,
you know, knows whether there's a
problem with the engine. They know
whether it's been making a sound every
time they drive it, right? So, the
seller knows
the condition of the car.
And that's probably relevant actually to
both of your valuations, right? If it's
a high-quality car, the seller probably
values it more cuz they could sell it to
someone else, the buyer probably values
it more as well. Um I'd argue the buyer
probably also has some private
information.
Uh what does the buyer
know uh the seller, and these are things
when I say the seller knows this, but
the buyer doesn't. Maybe I'll say
And of course, these things aren't
binary, right? The buyer probably knows
something about the car. They can look
at it and see, you know, if it's
totally, you know, dented, they can see
that, but there's probably some aspects
of the car that they can't see or can't
observe. Uh what about the buyer? What
is something the buyer may know? Yeah.
Uh I mean, yeah. The buyer knows like
how much they want a car, and like
I feel like that informs like how much
they'd be willing to pay for it.
Exactly. So, the buyer knows in this
exactly what you mentioned in the front
row, they know their valuation for the
car, right? Buyer knows
or at least they know Maybe they don't
know their valuation exactly, but they
know
maybe I'll say how much they need it.
The reason I don't say they don't know
their valuation is if they don't know
the If they don't know if the car is
broken or not, then they probably don't
know exactly how much it's really worth
to them. But, you know, they know Do
they have a job they need to get to
tomorrow, and they have to get there,
right? And And they know they went to
the last three dealerships and they
couldn't find a car they liked. Or maybe
they know that they like the color red
uh and this car is red or they hate the
color brown and that's why they value it
less, right? There's a lot of aspects of
the buyer's preferences that the buyer
knows but the seller doesn't.
And notice how this is fundamentally
different from the kind of
imperfect information we see in poker,
right? In poker, yes, I don't know if
you have queens or or kings, but when
you sit down at the table, we basically
all know the game we're playing and we
all know the preferences of the other
players.
Um
Another great example would be health
insurance.
So also buying health insurance.
I would argue in this case probably the
seller and the buyer know some things
that the other party doesn't know very
well. Um
Any thoughts here?
Certainly the buyer probably knows some
things the seller
uh
doesn't know. Yeah? The buyer knows his
own medical history and uh
Exactly. So the buyer knows medical
history.
And again, this is not binary, right? If
you buy health insurance in the private
market, the seller's concerned about
this and they're going to have you fill
out a form and they're going to have a
doctor go to your house and do a
30-minute evaluation. But of course,
that's not going to cover everything.
You might know that, you know, last week
you started feeling a bit sick and
that's why you're buying the health
insurance, right? Or you might know
about a family history of a condition
that the the health insurer doesn't know
about.
And this is certainly relevant to both
of you. It's relevant to how much you
value insurance cuz the sicker you are,
the more valuable insurance is to you.
It's also relevant to how costly the
insurance is to the seller. If the
seller insures a very sick person,
they're going to have to be on the hook
for a lot of different doctor's bills,
right? And this is one reason health
insurance markets
uh often don't run very well, right?
Um I'd argue the seller probably
even in this case maybe knows some
things.
Um
This is sort of not the main uh
missing information in health insurance
markets, but uh I think there's probably
some things they know. Yeah? Could the
seller know that their company is about
to do a discount next month but doesn't
tell the buyer? Great. That's That's a
good thing. So one thing I mean, that's
in a dynamic context, but certainly in a
dynamic context, the sellers know the
prices next period, right? This is a
huge This is certainly relevant, you
know, these clothing stores always do
these regular discounts, right? If you
go and buy something, if you knew that
they were going to have a 15% discount
the next day, you probably wouldn't buy,
right? And they usually don't tell you
that the discount's coming in the
future, right? They announce it when it
started. They don't tell you in advance.
So the seller might know uh things about
future pricing.
And maybe this is a bit more of a
behavioral kind of non-rational story,
but I would argue that when you buy
health insurance, it's very, very
complicated. The exact quality of the
network you have is very, very difficult
to you know, to untangle. So technically
when you buy a health insurance plan,
what's relevant to you is every single
doctor in the world who's covered by the
plan and who's not. And more precisely,
exactly how much your copay is at every
single doctor
uh maybe in the world. Right? You
probably don't know that that well even
if you pore through the contract. The
seller probably has a a much better idea
of maybe what I'll say, the network
coverage.
Or what they certainly know about is
when you apply
to get reimbursed for a treatment, how
cumbersome that process is. And what the
rejection rate is of the insurer. This
is something the insurer knows. Some
insurers might uh be a bit more lenient
than others. They they privately know
that. Maybe you go and read it and read
a bit about it, but it's you probably
don't have uh full information about
that.
Uh let's do
a few more examples.
Uh what about in an auction
context?
Well, here it's sort of the classic case
when the bidders show up to an auction,
the bidders generally know uh how much
they value the item being auctioned, but
the other bidders don't know that,
right? So each bidder
knows her value for the good.
And of course, this value could reflect
a few things, right? If I'm bidding
against someone in auction, their value
might be high because they just love
this painting or maybe they're just
really, really rich or maybe they just
got all this money and they have to
spend it today, you know, there's all
these stories that could go on, but
their willingness to pay for the item uh
is something that they know that that I
don't know.
Uh and then a classic case that we've
also discussed so far is maybe
bargaining
negotiation more broadly.
You know, let's say we gave the example
of kind of bargaining over a peace
treaty.
When we when both sides sit down at the
table, they don't really know what terms
of the treaty are acceptable, right? If
I'm negotiating with a foreign leader, I
mean, I'd never be doing that. Uh they
they know their political constraints at
home. They know what kind of deal they
can make that would get them in trouble
or not. They might know facts on the
ground. They might know uh things about
the condition of their soldiers in their
army that are all relevant to the
negotiation that I as the as the
counterparty don't know. So
um there's just tons of private
information.
I'll just say
about
really what is it about? It's about
their preferences
over the terms of the negotiation, over
terms of the deal.
So
I think it's it's nice to kind of step
back here and pause and look at the
history of of game theory. Game theory
started as I said earlier in the course,
it was studied by mathematicians. They
were analyzing things like chess and
checkers and poker
and they presented this theory of
complete information that did a very
good job of capturing games like chess
and checkers and poker. But there was
this folk wisdom, there was this view
that we could never apply game theory to
the real world, to things like this
because the game isn't common knowledge.
There's just so much information that we
don't know that we could never apply the
tools and the rigor of game theoretic
reasoning.
And there was a a big breakthrough in
the '60s. So the breakthrough kind of
came with
Harsanyi
in 1967, 1968
who presented a a framework for
uh analyzing situations like this using
game theory. And I think this was kind
of a turning point in game theory where
before that, it was largely studied by
mathematicians and then once people
realized that this is the right way to
think about health insurance markets or
bargaining, all of a sudden economists
became much more interested in it and
the the nature of the field kind of
shifted. And Harsanyi later won the
Nobel Prize for his work here.
So I think Harsanyi's kind of key
insight uh which was later formalized by
others is that
we can model
incomplete information
like we model
imperfect information.
So in other words, I think
as a sentence, this doesn't really make
much sense. So let's say what we mean.
What What Harsanyi said is maybe we can
model negotiation and health insurance
the way we model poker.
So why don't we think about someone's
health status in health care
or a foreign uh
you know, a military leader's private
information about their army the way we
model your hand in a game of poker?
So the key is that we don't literally
have a dealer who's dealing you cards,
but we can model this private
information as the move of a
metaphorical dealer or metaphorical move
by nature who deals people their private
information. So Harsanyi's idea is that
we can have
a metaphorical
first move
by nature.
And I want you to think about this. I
think the best way to think about this
is nature is playing the role of the
card dealer, but what they're dealing
you is your health status or how much
you value the painting or the condition
of your army.
Right?
And after nature makes that deal, then
we can analyze the game like a game of
imperfect information.
Now, I think a challenge here
uh is that
this is metaphorical. So I think
in poker, it's very clear
how we can reason through a situation
before the cards are dealt. If I'm
playing poker, I'm sitting at the table,
I don't have the cards yet. The dealer
deals me a card. I know that's going to
happen and I can think about what's, you
know, when that's going on. It's a bit
hard to think about you buying health
insurance at the stage before nature
dealt you your health status, right? So
So there is it is there is kind of this
subtlety in how we interpret it. Um but
despite the difficulty of
interpretation, so maybe I'll say uh
this creates some interpretational
difficulties.
AND WE'LL SEE THOSE THROUGHOUT UH THE
COURSE, but
uh nevertheless, we can analyze these
things mathematically and uh we can make
some progress. One difficulty, I guess,
in the first move by nature
is we have to specify the probability
distribution over what nature chooses.
That's a lot easier when nature's
drawing a card from a deck. We all
understand that. When nature's drawing
your health status or your evaluation
for a good, that becomes a bit more
challenging. So one challenge is that we
have to specify
the distribution
over nature's moves.
BUT LET'S SEE IF WE CAN GET INTO THIS
AND UH AND start analyzing this.
So I could present the whole general
model, but I think it's very complicated
at first and you might say why do we
need this complicated model? So let's
start with an example to try to motivate
why things are kind of subtle and why we
actually need to do some work to to
model this.
So, let's think about classic example.
Let's say we're working on a group
project.
And let's say we have two players.
And I'll call them
I equals 1 and I equals 2.
And each player I
is going to choose
effort on the project.
You're going to choose
effort
EI. They're player I, they choose effort
EI. And let's say that's a number
between 0 and 1.
So, 0 is they don't work at all. 1 is
they work as hard as they possibly can.
And now we're going to say the payoffs
to player I
well, player I's payoff depends on how
well the project turns out
minus the cost they have to bear to uh
exert effort. Let me see if I had a half
in here.
No. So, let's say that their payoff is
E1 * E2
minus
EI squared.
So, what this says is
E1 * E2, the product of the efforts that
the two players put in, this is going to
represent basically how good the project
is.
How good the output is.
And this is the cost of effort.
So, notice if I'm player I, my effort EI
affects my cost.
And it also affects the quality of the
output.
The other player's effort affects the
quality of the output, but not my cost
because I don't bear the cost for the
effort that the other player is putting
in.
This is a pretty simple game to analyze,
but the trick is we're now going to put
a theta up here.
Where theta is going to be a state that
represents how hard the project is. When
you get working on something together,
you often don't know how hard this task
is, right? Um
>> [clears throat]
>> So, theta is going to represent the
difficulty
of the project. Actually, a higher theta
means the project is easier. So, maybe
I'll I'll think of theta as how easy the
project is.
So, as a simple case, we could say
maybe two values
uh theta H
and theta L.
So, these are the two possible values
theta could take.
Theta H is a low value because if the
project is hard, when you put in this
much effort, you don't get very much
output.
If the project is easy, theta L, uh hard
and I guess I'm so used to high and low,
so easy. Theta H, theta E. If the
project is easy, then you get more
output for the same uh level of effort.
>> [clears throat]
>> The problem is you probably don't know
how hard the project is.
So, if
let's kind of think through a few cases
here.
So, the easy case, case 1 would be
no one knows theta.
If no one knows theta and they just
believe theta follows some distribution,
then
we can sort of analyze this as a classic
game because at the beginning of the
game, information is symmetric.
So, here this would be symmetric info.
If no one knows theta, then there's no
information that one player knows that
another player doesn't know.
But the harder case, let's look at case
where only player 1 knows theta.
So, if only player 1 knows theta
let's see if we can start
analyzing this game.
Well, in case 2
player 1 is going to possibly make a
different choice depending on how hard
the project is.
So, player 1 is going to make
maybe one choice
E1 if theta H
and a different choice
E2 if theta L, right? If player 1 knows
how hard the project is, if the project
is hard, they might find it not as
worthwhile to work on the project. Uh
this should be E1.
And this should be easy, so everything's
wrong here. Um
If they know the project is easy, they
might choose a different level of
effort, right? So, we're going to have
to capture that when we think about a
player's strategy in the game, player
1's strategy might depend on how hard
the project is, right?
But now let's look at player 2.
What should player 2 do? Let's imagine
you are in this situation.
You don't know how hard the project is.
And you're thinking about how hard to
work.
I don't know. I I think there's some
information that's missing here. There's
something you need to know.
Um so, we've said they don't know how
hard the project is.
They So, they don't know theta.
But I think we're missing some
information to see
how they should behave.
Um
don't know theta. I don't know, how
would you approach this if you were
player 2?
Yeah?
Maybe in terms of like a
security strategy kind Okay.
Um Like trying to minimize the
possibility that it goes wrong given
that I don't know if it's a
I'm not sure if you Okay, so that would
be one way. No, I think that would be a
reasonable answer. That's not We're not
going to pursue that too much in this
course, but that's something that people
do and that's one thing you can study.
Uh yeah, Eileen. I feel like
you if you know how much player 1 cares
about the project, you could kind of use
backwards induction like Okay. If player
1 knows theta and you know that player 1
cares a lot, you'll know that player 1
is just going to do the project so you
don't have to do anything. So, so I
think the first thing you said there was
really crucial. You said, "If player 1
knows theta." And then you reason from
that, right?
But does player 2 know that player 1
knows theta? Well, we need to make a
choice about that. So, this is the
crucial thing, right? It's not just
enough to say
I've said player 2 doesn't know whether
project is hard. But you immediately
gave it away. When you're reasoning
about this, I need to think through how
hard is player 1 going to work?
But how hard player 1 works is going to
depend on whether player 1 knows how
hard the project is. So, I need to
think, here's a question for the
analysis
does player 2
know
whether player 1 knows theta?
Because that's going to affect the way
that player 1 moves
and therefore affect the best thing for
player 2.
But now I think we're sort of getting
into a regress, right? Let's say you're
player 1, how are you thinking through
this?
What what's relevant now for player 1
when they're trying to think? We know
player 1 knows theta.
But player 1 needs to think, well, how
hard is player 2 going to work?
But how hard player 2 works depends on
whether player 2 knows whether player 1
knows theta.
So, now we have to think from player 1's
perspective
does player 1 know
whether player 2 knows whether player 1
knows theta?
And I think you can see where this is
going.
Right? Uh
we care about what the other player is
going to do. What they do depends on
their beliefs about what I know
but also their beliefs about what I know
that they know and my beliefs about what
they know that I know that they know and
it it kind of unravels here.
So, we need a way to kind of get a
handle on this.
And I think this is what was seen as the
key challenge to these games. At first,
you might think all we need to specify
is what each player knows about theta,
about the state of the world, how hard
the project is. But we soon realize that
to fully analyze the game, we need to
take a stance on what each player knows
about other what other people know and
what other people know about what other
people know and so on.
Uh and I so, the key kind of takeaway
here is that we really need to
distinguish two different aspects of the
game.
Uh so, I think this motivates a key
distinction
I don't need another arrow here.
Between the physical state theta.
This is in this example, how hard the
project is. It's totally outside the the
minds of the players. It's either hard
or it's easy. That's just some fact of
the world, fact of nature.
But then we also need to think about
maybe the mental state
of each player, which maybe before we
saw this example, we might have thought,
"Oh, mental state just means their
belief about theta." But now it really
means their belief
about the mental state of the other
player. And in general, we're going to
try to have this mental state capture
all the relevant beliefs about the the
physical state and also about the mental
state of the other player.
Uh and that's kind of the
the direction we're going to go now with
this uh formal setup.
Uh any questions about about this? So, I
don't expect you to see the solution,
but just to see that there's a problem
is kind of the goal of this example.
Okay.
>> So now we're going to formally present
our model of a game that can capture
incomplete information. And we're going
to be using Bayes' rule a lot, so these
games are often called Bayesian games.
So how do we
kind of try to capture a situation like
this?
Well, first we're going to have the
players.
I equals one up to N.
And then we're going to have the
actions.
So each player
So player I
is going to choose some action in some
action set.
So just like in repeated games,
it's if we were to call this a strategy
set, we would then run into issues
because in the meta Bayesian game
there's going to be a different notion
of strategy. So I want to use the term
action instead of strategy. I think the
notes talk about Bayesian games with
Bayesian extensive form games at this
part. We're not going to talk about that
at least for now, so we're going to
think of this is just a simultaneous
move game where each choosing an action
just like we did over there. We each
choose how hard to work.
Uh but then
there's going to be some state of
nature.
Uh maybe our physical state
or sometimes called a state of nature.
theta
which is going to be in some set big
theta. Um I don't know if we've used
theta before. When I write theta it just
looks like an H with a inside a circle,
but that's so that we can see the
difference. Little theta is like this,
big theta is like this. So I know it
looks weird, but that's that's how I
write it on the board.
And just so we understand how we map it
into our example over there, there we
had two players.
Each player's action was an effort
level, some effort level between zero
and one.
And the physical state was the
difficulty of the project, which over
there there were two states. It could
either be a difficult project H, a hard
project, or an easy project theta E, an
easy project.
Um and then we're going to need payoffs
just like we had over there.
So then we're going to have
utility
for player I.
This is going to depend on the actions
that every player takes, but also
potentially on the state of the world.
So just like over here, my payoff
depended on my own effort level, my
opponent's effort level, and also the
state of the project, how hard the
project was. So over here in the more
abstract context, UI is going to be a
function of A1
all the way up to AN, the actions of
every player, times
the set capital theta.
And it's going to go to R
for each I.
So this is going to give me a real
number payoff that depends on what
player one does, what player two does,
all the way up to what player N does,
and also the value of the physical
state. In this example, whether the
project is easy or hard.
Uh but what we see from that that game
is we haven't specified enough yet
because we also have to think about the
mental states, right? What players know
about other players.
And Harsanyi's key trick is to introduce
this abstract object which we call a
type.
And the type of a player is going to
capture their complete mental state. It
could be their beliefs about the state
of the world. It could be their beliefs
about the other player. It could be all
these things. Um so we're going to say
we have
uh
player I
has a type
TI
which is in some set
capital TI.
So this is called
player I's type space.
And type is kind of a a weird
terminology, but you can say there's the
type of the player who knows the state,
there's the type of the player who
doesn't know the state, there's the type
of the player who knows the other player
knows the state, but doesn't know the
state. We just think of these players
with different mental states as
different types of of players.
Okay.
>> [clears throat]
>> And
what we're missing here is what's the
connection between the types and the
state of the world, and we're going to
capture that with a prior. So the last
component here
is going to be
a distribution
P.
But it's not enough just to say the
distribution of the physical state, but
we also have to specify the distribution
of the players' types. And more
generally, we have to specify
um
the distribution over the combination of
natural states and types. So this
distribution P is going to be over
theta
cross
T1
cross TN.
So it's going to tell us what is the
probability that
the physical state is this,
player one's mental state is something,
all the way up to player N's mental
state being something over here. Uh I
think this is a bit abstract, so um
let's try to go through
our example. Maybe I'll give one
Yeah, so let's go try to capture this in
our example.
Where
I didn't specify everything.
Let's say does player two know
whether player one knows theta? We're
going to say for this example, yes.
[clears throat]
And does player one know whether player
two knows whether player one knows
theta? We're going to say yes. So we
could make it more complicated, but
we're going to say all these things are
are known. So in this example,
player one knows the state theta,
player two doesn't know the state theta,
but they do know that player one knows
the state theta.
And we're going to try to capture that
in our framework over here, okay? So the
first, I think, challenging step or
whenever we set up these models, the
first thing is to specify the state.
That's kind of easy, the state theta.
And then we have to specify the type
spaces, and that's always a bit harder.
So let's go through this example. What
is the state space theta going to be if
we want to capture our example of the
group project uh over there?
What were the physical states in in that
example?
Yeah.
Right. So we just have and actually
theta H and theta E. I wrote it wrong.
Uh
So
uh often we do high and low, but here
let's think of the project is hard or
the project is easy, right? These are
the two physical states. Did I write
L?
Okay, I don't know. I I did originally
make a mistake, so uh that's on me.
Okay.
But now the hard thing is specifying the
types. This is always the challenge,
right? So the next step is to specify
T1 and T2.
So I think the question you have to ask
yourself is
how many distinct mental states does
each player have?
Um
Any thoughts? Let's think about player
one.
So we know that player one, we know uh
player one knows the state.
So
what are some distinct mental states
that player one could have?
Uh
Yeah.
Yeah. Player one can know that player
two doesn't know the state. Player one
can know that player two
uh
doesn't know that player one knows the
state.
So there's a lot of things that could
happen, and this is why I tried to
simplify it by saying we're going to
assume that player one does know whether
player two knows the state. So in our So
you're right, if we really wanted to get
general, we'd have to deal with that,
but we're going to assume
player one, these higher order beliefs
are known. We're going to make it kind
of as simple as possible. So player one
does know all these things, but I would
still argue there's at least there's
certainly two different mental states
player one could have.
What are these two mental states? We
said player one knows the state, but
what does that mean?
What could player one believe?
They know the state well, either they
know the state is easy
or they know the state is hard. So
there's at least two mental states.
There's the type of player one where
they know this is a hard project,
and there's the other type of player one
where they know this is an easy project,
right? So in this case, if we really
went down this rabbit hole, we'd have to
make it harder, but in the simplest
example, there's actually only two
types.
And they exactly correspond to the
mental state where player one sees or
knows
the project is easy, and the mental
state where they see or know the project
is hard. Um
There's a pretty close correspondence
here, but to keep the distinction clear,
let's call this TH and TE.
So the interpretation is if player one's
type is TH, what does that mean? That
means player one knows the project is
hard. Notice that's different from
saying the state is state H, right? When
I say the state is state H, that's a
statement about whether the project is
actually hard or not.
When I say that player one's type is TH,
that's a statement about what what
player one knows or believes about the
state.
What about player two here? Uh it turns
out in this really simple case, there's
only one mental state for player two.
Because they don't know whether the
project is hard or easy. They do know
that player one knows that. So
they show up and they play the game.
There's there's only one possible type.
Uh so maybe we'll just call this
T T0 to show they don't they don't
really know anything.
So we now have specified the physical
states and the mental states. We could
have made it much more complicated if
there was uncertainty about what the
other players knew. We'd have to model
larger type spaces. But for this simple
example, we've made it
quite nice.
And
let's also assume
that theta H and theta L or theta E
are equally likely.
And this is known among the players.
So
to be clear, player two knows that it's
equally likely that the project is hard
or easy.
They know that player one knows that the
project is hard or knows that it's easy,
but they don't know anything else.
So now the challenge is can we describe
this distribution P?
So this distribution P is going to be a
distribution over theta cross T1
cross T2. So what we need to specify is
four different probabilities, right? So
we need to say what's the probability of
theta H
TH T0
theta H TL T0
theta E
Keep messing this up.
TH
T0
and theta E
TE
T0.
So sometimes these are called states of
the world. The distinction is theta is a
state of nature or physical state. The
state of the whole world specifies both
the physical state and the mental
states. So these are kind of the four
possible states of the world and let's
interpret them. Let's look at the second
one just as example. This is the state
of the world where the state of nature
is theta H. So the project is hard.
The player one's mental state is TE.
That means player one believes that the
project is easy.
And player two's mental state is just
T0. They believe what they always
believe. They don't really have anything
to believe. They just have the one thing
they know.
So
what we want to do is we need to assign
probabilities to each of these four
things based on the story we've told so
far.
So any thoughts on what this
probability distribution P is is going
to be here?
Yes, back here. Would it be 1/2 0
0 1/2? Exactly right.
So can you
explain a little bit why how you how you
got that?
So if state of the world theta H is
let's say theta is theta H. Yeah. That
means we know with absolute State of
nature, yeah, sorry. It's very
confusing. Yeah. If the state of nature
is theta H, yeah, exactly.
I may have messed it said said it wrong
myself, yeah.
Anyways, then with absolute certainty we
know that player one knows that the
state of nature is theta H, which means
they have TH. It's not possible for them
to have TE in this this mismatch, which
is why that gets probability zero. And
then kind of you flip the labels and
then everything else is symmetric.
Exactly. Exactly right. So
um
I guess it's sort of a hidden implicit
assumption that, you know, when we say
player one, well, this is what it means.
To know that the state is to know the
state means when you think the state is
high, it's actually high or hard. And
when you think the state is easy, it's
actually easy. Otherwise, you wouldn't
you wouldn't know the state.
Um
Okay, let's do
maybe one more
example to make sure we kind of uh can
understand what's going on here.
So let's consider maybe example two.
Where we'll try to be a little more
realistic. Probably player one can't
perfectly tell whether the the project
is easy or hard, right? But they have
some information about it. So what we're
going to imagine is
uh player one
gets a signal about the difficulty of
the state.
And so player one has some information
about whether the project is easy or
hard, but they don't know it for sure.
Uh and more specifically
so let's say player one, sometimes we
say
gets a signal.
And that's kind of a statistically way
of looking at it, but um you know you
sit down, you try to start doing your
homework, you think uh I think it's
probably hard, but I'm not sure. And you
maybe assign some probability to how
hard it is. Um and that's what we're
going to try to capture here. So
let's say that the
I'm going to say with accuracy
Q
where Q is going to be between
1/2 and 1.
So what this means is let me just kind
of
draw this mapping.
kind of
running out of arrows here.
So what I'm representing here is this is
I'm going to think of theta H and theta
L as the true difficulty of the project.
And I'm going to think of TH and TL as
kind of the signal that player one gets
about the difficulty of the project.
And if the project is hard, then most of
the time player one gets the signal
that's indicative of it being hard,
indeed with probability Q, but with
probability 1 minus Q, you know, it's
deceptively hard. It looks it's actually
hard, but it it looks easy and they get
the the wrong signal. And then we have
the same thing over here. So let's just
understand if I allowed Q to be one
then if the project is hard, they always
get the signal that it's hard. And I'm
just going to say L all day long and get
it wrong. Uh
but
when the project and similarly when the
project is easy, they always get this
signal that suggests it's easy. So the
case of Q equals one is exactly what we
already studied over here.
But now we're going to generalize to
this case. What if Q was a half? What
would that correspond to?
Yeah. You're right half the time. Right.
And if the prior, since we said, you
know, it's equally likely to be
hard and easy, it actually means you
know nothing.
Right? If you have a signal that you
know, when the state is
when the state is hard it gives you each
signal realization with probability
half. And when it's easy, you get each
half, then it's not giving you any
information at all. So you're just
totally uninformed, right? Your
your your gut is is totally useless,
right? Which is
uh maybe for
retail stock traders, that's a pretty
good model of um
of how they trade stock. So
let's now try to capture this model,
this example within our model over here,
right? So it turns out the type spaces
are going to be the same, but the
interpretation is different. So we still
have for player one two types, the hard
type and the easy type. But now the hard
type, we don't mean you know for certain
the project is hard. What we mean is
based on the evidence you see, it's more
likely than not that the project is
hard.
And similarly, the the type TE is
suggests that player one looks at the
project, they think it's probably easy,
but they're not certain that it's easy.
And they can actually compute the
probability that it's easy.
So now let's represent this.
We're going to represent this
with the distribution
P
over
theta cross T1
cross T2.
Uh so what is it going to be? Let's
write it down. Again, we have theta H
TH T0
we have theta H
TE T0
we have theta E TH
T0 and we have theta E
TE
T0.
I guess they got progressively smaller
as I ran out of space. Okay.
So now what are the probabilities that
we're going to assign
to each of these?
Yeah. Just to make sure there is equal
probability that it actually is hard.
We're going to maintain that assumption.
So good good question. Let's let's
maintain this assumption. I didn't say
that. Yeah.
Yes. Second row, yeah. So for the first
one, there's a 1/2 chance that it's
hard. Yeah.
>> And then as for TH, that would like
that's going to be uh
Okay, so what's the full the probability
of this uh That's 1/2 Q. 1/2 Q, exactly.
And then
uh 1 minus Q. Yes. And then 1/2
1 minus Q.
Okay.
So it's going to be like this. Because
what has to happen for this to be the
state of the world? Well, first the
project has to be hard.
And we know that happens with
probability 1/2.
But further, not only is the project
hard, but player one gets the signal
that's indicative of it being hard.
And when the state's actually hard, how
likely is that? That's probability Q.
And then down here, well, it's kind of
the it's we're going to say, well,
there's still a probability half that
the state is uh that it's actually hard,
but now what's the probability they get
the the easy signal? So, they get
misled, they get the signal that
suggests the project is easy even when
it's hard. That's still possible. It's
less likely, but it's possible. That has
probability 1 minus Q, and we have to
multiply that by a half.
Um
Notice here, if we sum the first two,
we get a half,
which makes sense because the sum of the
first two is exactly the probability
that the state is hard because we're
summing uh given the state is hard,
we're summing the over the the
additional types. Um let's look at the
extreme cases. If Q goes to 1, what
happens here?
Well, now we're just back over here,
right? This is what we said. This is the
special case where player one perfectly
observes the difficulty of the project.
What if Q goes to a half?
Yeah.
If Q goes to a half, then each of like
the pairs like the data H pairs and the
data E pairs are constantly going to be
1/4.
Right. So, basically everything's a
fourth because now your signal doesn't
really give you any information about
this. If this if the project is actually
hard, you're equally likely to get these
two signals, and just everything is is
going to be 1/4.
Um yes. Is player one aware of their own
Q, or does that even matter?
Uh no, it really it really does matter.
So, this is kind of the subtle thing
here that
and this is where
um the implicit assumption here, and
this is where it gets a little subtle,
is that the distribution P is common
knowledge.
So, player one knows their own type,
and
they know the set of possible types the
players have, and they know the
distribution over the types.
Now, you might say,
is that a restriction? It turns out
there's some really subtle mathematical
points that argue that as long as you
make the type space big enough, um
Okay.
The P is a little tricky. Basically, you
can make the type space big enough, and
you can capture everything, but it's
it's it's quite a subtle point about
what's known and what's not known, and
we're kind of getting into this very
abstract area of epistemic game theory
uh that kind of gets into logic and
uh and and really subtleties about what
what belief and what knowledge is. Uh
but, the assumption here is that P is is
known by everyone. Uh yeah.
Um Okay. So, the next thing we want to
do is
uh
let's
now think about behavior in this game.
So, so far I've just defined the game.
We now have to define
the remaining time we're going to define
an equilibrium of this game.
So far I've just defined what a Bayesian
game is. Let's now define what an
equilibrium of a Bayesian game is. The
first step is to define an equilibrium,
you always have to define what a
strategy is.
Okay? So, now let's define a strategy in
a Bayesian game.
Now, a strategy, remember, is always a
complete contingent plan.
It specifies what action you take as a
function of things that you can observe,
things that you know.
So, in this case for player I,
a strategy is a function
SI
from TI
to AI.
Let's kind of visualize it down here. We
have some type TI,
and that gets mapped
to SI of TI.
So, what this complete contingent plan
says is it says, "If I'm player I,
if my mental state is TI, this is the
action I'm going to take."
If I have a different mental state, I
can potentially take a different action.
My strategy can't depend on the mental
states of anyone else or on the state of
the world at the state of nature because
I don't observe those things. All I know
as player I is my mental state. So, the
only thing I can contingent condition my
action on is my own mental state. And
that's exactly why this function depends
on my mental state, but on no one else's
mental state.
Um
I think one
there's one subtlety here in
interpretation,
which is that
I'll say, "Note,
player I actually has
one mental state
/type.
So, this is where I mentioned the
interpretive difficulties we get into,
right? I'm calling this a complete
contingent plan,
but it's never clear when you would make
this complete contingent plan. You'd
have to make this complete contingent
plan before you know what your type is.
And you and, you know, it's very hard
with these intrinsic preferences, right?
You're born, let's say you like the
color red in our car example. Formally,
what you'd have to do here is make a
strategy that said, "If I were born and
I like the color blue, what would I do?
If I were born differently and like the
color red, what would I do?" It's kind
of a bit weird to think about,
um but I think the role of this
assumption really is that, yes, player I
is only going to have a single realized
type, and they're going to take a single
action based on that type.
But, the reason we have to specify this
complete contingent plan is that the
other players don't know what type
player I has. So, the other players are
going to have to form beliefs about
player I's type,
and then form beliefs about what actions
player I takes, and the other players
need to
So, what this represents is what the
other players believe player I will do
when player I's type is TI, even if
player I wakes up and their type is not
TI.
Um maybe a little kind of philosophical
uh digression, but let's just uh stop
there.
Yes. So, the fact that the strategy is
uh basically information that everybody
has, like everyone knows everyone else's
strategy.
Uh
so, this is sort of a subtlety. Normally
in game theory,
we make
knowledge assumptions not about what
people do, but about what people know
and about the the circumstance, and then
we define a solution concept like an
equilibrium.
Um
So, yeah, do people know This is always
a subtle thing. Do people know the
strategies that are chosen in
equilibrium?
Um I don't think we would formally say
people
know them. We would say that uh
equilibrium
specifies the beliefs that players have,
and a demand of equilibrium is that
those beliefs are correct.
But, we don't literally if we wanted to
model the game where you actually
observed player strategies, that would
be a different game, and we don't really
we we generally only model knowledge
about exogenous things from nature. We
don't really think about knowledge about
what other rational players do because
um
you know, that's just not kind of a
probabilistic process in the same way.
It's that that's in their controls. This
sort of gets into weird things about
free will and all these things, but the
point is we don't assume knowledge of
other people's strategies. Yeah. Uh but,
our equilibrium cons in in equilibrium,
people's beliefs about other people's
strategies will be correct, and that's
very similar, but I would say slightly
different. Yeah.
So, where does the part come in where
other players have to understand, "Oh,
if player I is born like red,
When we define equilibrium. So, I
haven't defined equilibrium yet, so
we'll see when we when we define
equilibrium. That's a great that's a
great question. Yeah.
Okay. So, the final step uh when to
define equilibrium is you have to say a
little bit more about beliefs. Let's put
ourselves in the position of player I.
Okay? Suppose I'm player I.
What I know
is I know my type.
So, let's say my type is TI. Okay?
Now, I have to decide how to play. I
have to decide what action to take.
But, the action for me
is going to depend on a lot of other
things. So, the first step is what I
need to do is I need to form beliefs
about
theta
and about T negative I.
I need to form beliefs about the
state of nature theta
and about the types of other players.
Okay?
In this model,
why do I need to form beliefs about
theta? Why do I care about theta? Well,
theta directly affects my payoffs. So,
going back to the example over here, I
need to form beliefs about how hard the
project is because the project is really
hard, I might not want to work very
hard, it may not be worth it, right? The
second subtler thing is, why do I need
to form beliefs about other players'
mental states?
Let's think of the project example. Why
do I care what another player thinks
about how hard the project is?
Uh yeah, in the front. They'll probably
adjust their effort accordingly.
Exactly. So, I care about their mental
states not because their mental states
directly affect my payoff, but because
their mental states will affect the
actions that they take, and the actions
that they take will affect my payoff.
And this is where going back to your
question about the red blue thing,
I'm forming beliefs about their mental
states, and then their strategy is going
to specify what they actually do under
those mental states. So, it's that
combination that's going to give me
information.
So, the first thing is we have to learn
how to use Bayes' rule. Um so, let's
maybe
to do this, we use Bayes' rule.
Bayes' rule.
So, let's say
we'll write something like this. What
does this mean?
PI says, "I'm player I."
TI says, "This is my mental state TI."
Given that this is my mental state, I
want to say, "What is the probability
that the the state of nature is theta,
and the mental states of all my
opponents are T negative I?"
Okay?
And this is going to be a classic
application of Bayes' rule. I hope
people have um seen this before. If you
haven't, it may be something you have to
brush up up on a little bit.
But what is this? Well, the probability
of A given B is the probability of A and
B divided by the probability of B. This
is what Bayes' rule says, and I'm going
to go over it too fast, so if you
haven't seen it, this won't make sense.
Just I think you have to study it on
your own. I'm happy to talk after class.
So, what are we going to get? On the
top, we're going to have the probability
that my type is TI and this is the state
of the world. So, we're going to get
theta
TI T negative I.
On the bottom, we want the probability
of TI. This is a little more subtle.
It's going to be a sum
over all maybe theta prime
T negative I prime
of P of theta prime.
And in words, this is the
probability of
TI.
So, Bayes' rule is what allows me to
leverage the prior distribution P, which
as we said everyone knows, to update my
beliefs and form my beliefs and assign
probabilities to the state of nature and
to other people's mental states as a
function of my mental state. And in
general, this probability here could
vary with my mental state. If I had a
different mental state, I would form
different beliefs about the other
players.
Okay, so now I think we can finally
write down
the definition of equilibrium.
So, let's uh
let's maybe go down here.
It's a it's a bit of a long definition,
so I really just want to spend the last
15 minutes just writing down one
equation to make sure we really
understand it.
So, we have our
Bayesian game over there.
And here's our definition.
So, a strategy profile
S star
which equals
S1 star to SN star. So, as usual
throughout the course, whenever we
define an equilibrium, the object that
an equilibrium is is always a strategy
profile. It's a specification of a
strategy for each player.
So, a strategy profile
is a
Well, what do we call this? Well, it's a
Nash equilibrium in a Bayesian game. So,
we call that a Bayesian Nash
equilibrium. We just put the words
together. Is a Bayesian Nash
equilibrium.
If
well
what's the basic idea about an
equilibrium? In equilibrium, every
player
is choosing their action optimally given
the beliefs they have about the other
players and those beliefs are correct.
So, we want to make sure that everyone
is behaving optimally given the way
everyone else is behaving.
So
I think the first step is to figure out
what we need to quantify over.
So, what we want to consider is we want
to say for every player
and for every mental state that player
could have, they're behaving optimally,
right? So, if
for every player I
and
for every type
TI
in capital TI
the following holds, okay? So, just
let's understand in words what we want
to write here. What we want to capture
down here is to say that
when player I
has mental state TI
the action they're choosing is optimal
given their beliefs.
And because we're requiring that for
every player I and for every type TI, uh
that's that's capturing what we want.
Okay? So, first let's compute what is
the expected payoff of the player of
type TI.
So, what we're going to do is we're
going to take an expectation.
And when I write this
I'm going to probably need a bit more
space.
I'm going to put something in here.
But what I'm writing when I write the
expectation given TI is I'm saying given
TI, I can form I can compute conditional
probabilities of
these other things and what I'm going to
put in here is going to be a function
of these things and I'm computing the
conditional expectation of that quantity
given my type TI, okay? So, what I want
to put in here is my payoff when we all
follow these strategies, okay?
So, it's going to be my payoff. I'm
player I.
Now, my payoff depends on
the actions that we all take and the
state of the world, the state of nature.
So, my player one's action is going to
be
what? Well, player one's action is going
to be S1
star
of T1.
And this is exactly reflecting the point
we made that why do I as player I care
about player one's mental state about
their T1? Because their T1 affects the
action that they're taking uh under this
equilibrium strategy profile. And then
it's going to go all the way up to SN
star
of TN.
Okay?
Now, it's tricky. One of these things,
the Ith position here is actually
something I'm controlling as player I,
but for everyone other than player I,
these are random things that I'm forming
beliefs about.
So, here we have the action profile and
then the final thing is
the theta.
Okay?
So, what you can think of it in here is
if the state of the world, not the state
of nature, but if the state of the world
is theta T1 all the way up to TN
then under the strategy profile, these
are the actions that all the players are
going to take.
This is the state of nature and
therefore player I's payoff is this and
player I is simply computing
expectations over that.
Questions about that?
Okay.
So, we want to compare that
to what happens if player I deviates.
Okay? So, what I want is I want to now
compute the same expected payoff if
player I chooses some action, let's say
AI prime.
And we're going to want this to be true
for all actions
AI prime.
So, it's also going to be
a conditional expectation
given TI.
And it's a little tricky that the Ith
component here is like hidden amongst
the rest, so I want to kind of
reorganize this a little bit. Uh so,
another way of writing this
which is useful
is to write this as
SI star TI
comma S negative I star
T negative I.
This is just notation where I'm going to
put player I first and put everyone
else's uh grouped together over here.
This is really I think misleading
notation when I write S negative I of T
negative I because really this is a
collection of functions, each of which
depends on a single player's type. So,
this is like
S2 star, let's say player I is is one.
This is S2 star of T2, S3 star of T3, S4
star of T4 and so on. It's a little
subtle, but um that's just going on
here.
Okay, and then what do I have over here?
Well, I'm player I. I'm unilaterally
deviating, so I'm taking instead of
taking action SI star of TI, which I'm
supposed to take, I'm instead choosing
action AI prime.
So, we have AI prime here.
But everyone else's action is still the
same.
So, they're still having S negative I
star
T negative I.
But then my payoff also depends on the
state.
So, we have the state here.
And this is
our definition.
And this is sort of to return to this
question of do I like blue or red? When
I'm player I
I'm forming beliefs about the other
player and I might not know if they like
blue or red. So, I'm taking into account
there's some probability they like blue
and this is the action they take.
There's some probability they like red,
this is the action they take. Even
though when they wake up in the morning,
they either like blue or red and they're
going to take a single action.
Yes. Is there a reason why we have the
condition that's given TI based on the
fact that you can only technically have
your like SI star for a certain TI
and then the computer knows your own
mental state before you compute the
strategy?
Um
So, I think there's two separate
questions there, right? One question is
why does the strategy why is the domain
of S1 star T1?
And why do I have this conditioning
here, right? So, it's two questions. One
is why is the strategy a function from
my type to my action? It's because I can
only
the only thing I know is my type. So,
the only thing that my action can depend
on is my own type. It can't depend on
things I don't observe. Just like in
poker, my strategy can't be
bet if my hand is higher than the other
person cuz I don't know his hand, right?
So, of course that would be a great
strategy, but it's not a legitimate
strategy because I don't know what the
other player's uh hand is. So, that's
why
S1 star is defined as a function of
player one's type only. Now, we go here
and this is let's think about the
decision stage. When I'm called upon
when I wake up and make a decision, I
know something. I know my own mental
state. If I'm player I, I know my mental
state TI
and that gives me information. I'm going
to update my beliefs based upon that.
So, in the same way
going back to our example here, when
player one knows the project is hard,
they have a different belief about
whether the project is hard than if they
wake up and they know the project is
easy and they're going to behave
differently in those situations. This is
exactly reflecting that, right? It's
reflecting the fact that my mental state
controls what I believe about this data.
So, just to to understand, if we put in
a different TI here,
this conditional expectation would
change because the belief about theta
and about everyone else's mental states
could be different if this TI were a
different TI, if it were TI prime. So,
each
TI, like TI and TI prime, basically lead
to different vectors of probabilities
for
other people's mental states as well as
theta. Exactly right. So, remember we
wrote down this formula here.
This is really a whole vector because
once I keep fixed TI, I can vary the
theta and the T negative I.
So, it's really a vector of
probabilities. It's a lottery over
everything I don't know, over all the
theta T negative I pairs.
So, this is kind of similar to how we
talked about like beliefs
Exactly. No, it's exactly a belief. I
mean,
what we're talking about precisely is
given my TI, I form beliefs. The tricky
thing is what I form beliefs about is T1
through TN and theta.
T1 and my belief about T1 through TN by
itself isn't that useful,
but when combined with the strategy the
opponents the other players use, now it
becomes useful, right? Just knowing that
the other player's mental state is T2
prime doesn't tell me much, but in
equilibrium, I correctly anticipate that
they're using the strategy S2 star, so I
can anticipate that the action they take
is S2 star of T2 double prime, and then
that gives me information. Yeah.
Any other questions? Yeah. Yeah, I think
you did just say, but just
>> No, no, no, this is good. Yeah, this No,
no, no, that's another player has a type
belief
not belief, uh type T2 that they're
going to do this action. Yeah, we can we
know that for sure.
Uh so, this is getting into the I guess
the notion of equilibrium. So,
uh
Like, if we It's yeah, I I think the
answer the short answer is yes, if you
want to get the problems right. If you
want to be really subtle about what what
knowledge means, um
we're saying
I guess one way of thinking of calling
this as a base Nash equilibrium is if we
all believe that these are the strategy
profiles we're employing,
then no one has an incentive to deviate
from the way they're behaving.
Um so, it's sort of capturing the idea
of Nash equilibrium that I'm believing
So, just like in Nash, right? In Nash,
we say, "I'm believing my opponents are
following this strategy, and given that
belief, I'm behaving optimally." If I
believe that my opponents all follow
this those strategy profiles, then it's
optimal for me to follow my my strategy
profile. And then that's that works for
everyone, so we sort of have this
consistency. Um but I guess
I would say there's a bit of a
distinction between
maybe this is this is a point.
Given TI,
I
form beliefs about T1 through TN and
theta. These are totally
outside the control of people. This is
just sort of something about the world I
can form those beliefs.
Then the mapping from their types to the
actions they actually take, that's
something that's under control of a
rational decision maker, and we kind of
view that differently. So, generally,
you know, I guess this gets to a broader
point in game theory. We sort of view a
fundamental difference between when I
form beliefs about whether
a dealt hand is going to be um kings or
aces and whether my opponent is going to
bet a certain amount cuz one is a choice
of a rational player, and the other is
just something that's chosen by nature.
So, we sort of maintain a distinction
there uh in game theory. So, you know
how a player how another player will
play given a certain hand, but you don't
know
Um
yeah, I would say you uh
you have beliefs about the hand they
will have,
and then in equilibrium, the equilibrium
describes consistent beliefs about the
way they're going to play. Yeah. Um but
I guess maybe another way of saying it
is
if I change the strategies,
so, yeah, this is maybe the key point.
This is independent of strategies.
The belief the probability I assign to
the other player having this type is
totally independent of of of how they
play. This is not a statement about
their behavior. This is just a statement
about the world.
Equilibrium is now a statement about
about behavior, but there's kind of this
this fundamental difference there, but
these these are subtle things, so these
are great questions to be asking. Yes.
So, that just means like
in So, here this is just over other
people's beliefs, but then
here it's like what you actually think
about what other people are going to
play.
Exactly. So,
sort of by definition of my mental
state, my mental state kind of defines
the beliefs I have about other people's
mental states.
Right? But that alone doesn't tell me
give me allow me to form beliefs about
other people's actions because in
general I don't know the mapping from
their mental states to their actions.
We've defined equilibrium to be a
profile of strategies that kind of
allows me to link my beliefs about their
mental states to my beliefs that about
their actions, and we apply the
classical idea of Nash equilibrium that
says that uh this method of behavior is
stable and consistent in the sense that
if everyone correctly believes that
everyone's playing this way, then no
one's going to want to deviate from this
method of play.
So, this is based on what you think
other people are going to play, but you
already based that on like what you
think their beliefs will be.
Um
yeah, uh
I would say
yeah, I I think my the short answer is
this calculation is not an equilibrium
object. This is a calculation that's a
property of the game itself.
This calculation is a a property of the
strategies and of the equilibrium
concept. Um maybe I'll just stop there.
Let me say one more thing that maybe
maybe is useful
to see how we can tie this in to our
notion of of Nash equilibrium. So, one
way
Actually, one thing I should have sort
of said before, when we're computing
these conditional expectations,
you get into some weird issues when you
condition on zero probability events.
So, what I've sort of assumed throughout
and maybe I'll say it now, I should have
said it before, assume that
this distribution P is strictly
positive.
So, it assigns positive probability to
everything um
uh every combination of of states and
types.
Say again? The simple case in the
beginning.
Good. Okay, so I was going to try to
avoid that simplicity, but
No, no, no, so let me say no. So, when I
say strictly positive, really what I
mean is I don't know. You're you're
exactly right. Um
Yeah.
No, no, no. I should do it. I was I was
going to skip a step, but you're right.
It's it's it's good not to.
Uh
So, this is really what I mean. It's not
that every combination has positive
probability, but every type of every
player gets positive probability. And
the reason I didn't want to write this
out is what does this mean? I have to
take a summation in order to compute
this, right? This is a summation over
all the other things. So, it's true that
there are some zeros here, but the
probability that player two has type
zero is one. The probability that player
one has type H is half, and the
probability that the other player has
type E is half. So, that's really what I
mean by positive probability, and that's
actually not lost cuz if something has
zero probability, I could just throw it
out and not include it in the type
space.
Yeah. So, thanks thanks for catching me
on that. I just tried to skip a step,
but you you kept me honest. Thank Um and
and you'll see that's because when I'm
conditioning, I'm conditioning on an
event about my type alone. I'm not
conditioning on richer things, and
that's why I only need that to be
positive probability.
Okay.
Uh so, if we want to kind of understand
what's going on here, one thing we could
do
is we could define
a new utility function directly over
strategies. So, we could kind of try to
reduce this game and express it purely
in strategic form. So, we could say
you I'm going to write capital UI of S1
up to SN.
And this is going to say, "What is my ex
ante expected utility if we all follow
these strategies?"
And now I'm going to take an expectation
not conditional
on TI, just expectation kind of before
we learn any of our types,
and it's going to be
UI
of
S1 T1
SN TN
theta
where here the expectation is just with
respect to this probability distribution
P here because the probability
distribution P specifies the joint
distribution of T1 up to TN and theta.
So, it makes sense to talk about this
expectation. It's a bit of a weird
object to think about because this is
this weird calculation that you make
before you're born and you know whether
you like blue or red. It's a weird
thing, but but we can define this.
So, now once we've defined this, we have
a classic strategic form game. We can
say what is the expected utility of each
player I as a function of the strategies
that are used.
And now we have a kind of a theorem.
I mean, it's a pretty basic theorem,
but
we say that
a strategy profile
S star
equals S1
star to SN star
is a base Nash equilibrium
of the Bayesian game
if and only if
S star
is a Nash equilibrium
of the strategic form game defined here.
>> And I think this is kind of a good
homework exercise to try to
go through and uh
and verify this. Yes. Why is it defined
over P?
Um I mean all these are implicitly
defined over P. Maybe I'll put P here.
But I guess the point I was trying to
make is that
this is a conditional expectation using
conditional probabilities given TI.
This is an unconditional expectation
using unconditional probabilities over
P.
That That's the only point I wanted to
make.
It's the same P. Yeah.
All right. Sorry. This is the P based on
Bayes' rule.
Uh I mean P is a distribution.
Using P I can compute conditional
probabilities here.
Here I don't even have to compute
conditional probabilities because P is
already a distribution over T1 up to TN
and theta.
And maybe just two words about the
intuition for this.
What this says is
whatever type I have, I'm behaving
optimally.
This is saying let's imagine I'm in the
position before I learn my type
and I'm
it's saying that my complete contingent
plan is optimal in expectation, but
that's a complete contingent plan is
only optimal if at every realization of
my type it's optimal. Um and that's sort
of the the connection here. That if I
anticipate that I'm going to make a
mistake at some type realization, then
there must be a mistake in my complete
contingent plan. Uh and that's the
connection here, but I think it's good
to maybe write it out in algebra as a as
an exercise. But let me stop there. I'm
happy to stick around for questions, but
uh let me conclude there. And I know
this is kind of
abstract. It's not It's It's natural for
this not to make so much sense the first
time, but I think doing problem sets
will really uh reinforce this.
Thanks.